[Musik]
in 16 Tagen startet die Fußball-WM in
Katar das Thema Menschenrechte sorgt im
Vorfeld für Aufregung feiern oder
boykottieren meine großartigen Gäste
heute Abend der legendäre
Sportjournalist und Fußballkommentator
Marcel Reif erblickt der WM in Katar
positiv entgegen und findet wir sind
keine schlechten Menschen wenn wir die
Spiele schauen es wird spannend sein zu
sehen wie er das einordnet wenn es
nämlich halsky erst Deutschland-Chef von
Human white Swatch und Menschenrechtler
ist müssen Sie nur noch eingeblendet
werden es war immer noch Herr reif jetzt
lernen Sie aber auch herrlich halsky
Kenntnis mit eine spannende Debatte
zwischen den beiden außerdem mit dabei
Landwirt Anthony Robert Lee er wird
heute Abend über die Frage sprechen ob
Deutschland sich überhaupt noch selbst
ernähren kann und
CDU-Politikerin dr Ottilie klein die im
Bundestag echte Debatten und
Streitkultur vermisst schön dass Sie
alle da sind mich hat heute eine Meldung
der Sportschau beschäftigt die für
Furore gesorgt hat die Nachricht
bezahlte Fanreisen zur catar-wm das
klingt ja erstmal wie das Märchen eine
gute Fee erscheint und verteilt mit
ihrem glitzernden Zauberstab ein
leidenschaftlicher Fans Flüge
Unterbringung und sogar taschengelder
zur WM klingt doch großartig doch in
diesem Fall ist die gute Fee eher der
böse Wolf denn die kostenlosen Fanreisen
beinhalten ein Verhaltenskodex also die
Reise der Fans wird bezahlt damit sie
dort und in den sozialen Netzwerken für
gute Stimmung sorgen und 450 Fans aus 59
Ländern seinen beteiligt die Teilnehmer
des fanlieder-netzwerks müssen unter dem
Slogan Katar the fans World Cup und dem
Hashtag im Fan fröhlich posten die
Teilnehmenden Fans die wissen auch also
deren Reise bezahlt wird dass ihre
Social Media Beiträge beobachtet werden
man behält sich auch das Recht vor
Änderungen oder das Löschen von Post zu
verlangen
ja da muss ich direkt Herrn Ralf Fragen
ist es denn schon so bitter steht es so
bitter um die WM der sieht schon Fans
zum Klatschen eingeflogen werden müssen
auch es steht in vielen Dingen bitter
genug aber das ist so eine die nächste
Pointe in in dem ganzen reichen gestern
gab es habe ich gelesen Spionage die in
der FIFA hinter jedem heerspioniert gut
also oder eben nicht gut aber sind das
wirklich Fans wie wurden die ausgewählt
oder sind das
influencer die von denen sie genau
wussten dass sie eine Reichweite haben
es sind es sind Fans also es ist jetzt
nicht wie wenn jetzt beispielsweise
irgendeine Automarke sich Influenza
einfliegen lässt da wird wahrscheinlich
auch auf Reichweiten geguckt werden
das stimmt spannend fand ich aber auch
es werden direkt Menschen ausgeschlossen
mit einer bestimmten politischen
Gesinnung also es wird direkt auch
danach geschaut wessen politische
Gesinnung man hat wie man eingestellt
ist und man darf nur fröhlich berichten
und zum Beispiel ich glaube wenn
influencer von Automarken beispielsweise
genommen werden sollten Sie ja auch
einigermaßen freiberichten dürfen hoffe
ich mal und dann sagen das alles also
nicht um beruflich da habe ich meine
Zweifel ob es wirklich fertig sind die
ausgewählt worden und nach die das
wirklich mit dem mit der mit der
Gießkanne gemacht also die kathari sind
nicht doof das sollten wir mal zur
Kenntnis nehmen das sind Methoden von
denen du sagst einmal aber das ist doch
nicht unser Standard das ist ja Wahnsinn
so ja aber sie werden es so tun und wir
werden ja heute ein bisschen drüber
reden ich habe ein Problem heute zu
sagen es ist alles schlimm bei der
Vergabe 2010 da hätte man all diese
Kriterien anlegen müssen und der hätte
gerade niemals niemals diese WM bekommen
können heute müssen wir gucken wie wir
mit den Dingen die da passieren zu
rangekommen und drauf hoffen dass ich
ein bisschen was tut aber wenn wir bei
diesem Fan Beispiel bleiben gab es das
denn auch bei anderen WMS dass Fans
eingeladen wurden unter Hashtags und
gute Stimmung zu machen oder ist es
jetzt schon was ganz Neues und auch
erschreckend
diese WM ja eine eine andere WM ist als
als alle anderen ich kann mich nicht
erinnern dass selbst Russland 2018 da
war die Krim schon annektiert hatte ich
nicht den Eindruck dass die ganze Welt
auf jault sondern dabei das hat man so
ein bisschen stillschweigend zur
Kenntnis genommen Russland wurden die
Fans nicht zum Klatschen eingezogen aber
hier ist es offenbar nötig denn
natürlich ist diese WM so so toxisch und
so belastet mit mit 1000 Dingen und zwar
wirklich wichtigen Dingen dass das kein
normaler Fußball sein wird und das ist
die Kritik gibt ist das Normalste von
der Welt und das dann aber der
Betroffene wenn er glaubt und wenn das
seine Denkweise ist das mit Geld lässt
sich alles regeln und das ist so
dass sie sich dann solche Methoden
bedienen das ist nicht unser Standard
deswegen ich die bähme den nie dort
stattfinden sollen nur jetzt dass ich
das stattfindet bringt sehe ich ihn wenn
man darüber reden sehe ich in Boykott
keinen Sinn Helli würden sie sich
bezahlen lassen um zur WM zu fliegen
also würden sie es Angebot annehmen
kostenlose Unterbringung kostenlose
Flüge kostenloses Ticket dafür net
Posten ja na klar ich bin Fußballfan
selbstverständlich wie ich es gucken und
ich finde es auch abenteuerlich und auch
ein bisschen lächerlich und scheinheilig
was wir jetzt für eine Debatte führen
also so kurz vor der WM das hätte man
wie Herr Ralf völlig richtig sagt gleich
nach der Vergabe es jeden Menschen
mit Abstand schlechteste Bewerbung mit
Abstand und jeder und sagt auch
sonst wäre England zugekommen richtig
England Australien war in der waren
einige in der Verlosung
Nachhaltigkeit da werden das weiß ja
jeder Stadien gebaut in der Wüste
klimatisiert Menschenrechte ich glaube
der hat getitel sechseinhalb tausend
Menschen sind umgekommen bei dem Bau ist
doch ist doch jetzt eine ja und Katar
weigert sich auch die Fonds zu machen
oder aufzustellen um die jetzt zu
entschädigen die Frage ist ihr wie man
Menschenleben entschädigen möchte dass
er jetzt eh weiterhin gestellt aber wie
also diese klatschenden Fans da würden
sie mitmachen ich würde mir das Spiel
angucken ich feiere nicht einfliegen
lassen auf Kosten von Katar doch na klar
ich bin natürlich würde ich das machen
weil was bringt es denn die WM findet
trotzdem statt auch wenn wir jetzt sagen
ich gucke das nicht ich habe gestern
eine Umfrage gesehen wer zu Hause
boykottiert am Fernseher interessiert
das die scheiß ich glaube doch nicht
wirklich deswegen gleich zum Propaganda
bitte machen
um als clarkeur dazu irgendwie ein
Hashtags das war nicht die Frage ob ich
hinfahren würde auf Kosten von den
cataris ja eben aber nicht diese
Aktionen starten das würde natürlich
machen ich lasse mir ich prostituieren
das ist ja klar
aber nichts posten natürlich okay
[Gelächter]
ich jetzt selbst die Katar
isiert sogar noch mit human white Swatch
haben sie Instagram Account wäre super
für die Kataris ja es wäre den
theoretisch zuzutrauen denn es sind
PR-Profis und damit hätten wir
vielleicht uns auf ihrer Seite aber ich
glaube im realen Leben würden die mich
nicht einladen die mögen mich nicht weil
ich zu lange es ist eben nicht erst
jetzt dass die Kritik da ist sondern wir
haben schon vor der Vergabe der WM auf
die Misere auf die Missstände auf den
Baustellen in Katar aufmerksam gemacht
als dann außerdem dieses
unterdrückerland dieses autoritär
geführte Land die
Weltmeisterschaft geschenkt bekommen hat
oder das war nicht ganz billig okay gut
aber das sieht dass sie eben das durfte
bekommen hat das hätten da gebe ich
Masse reif absolut Recht hätte nie
passieren dürfen so jetzt ist Katar wie
das eben war schon angedeutet wurde das
sind
PR-Spezialisten es gab einige
Verbesserungen das nicht gewundert mit
den Fans jetzt diese die Sache hat mich
z.B heute sehr verwundert doch aber es
ist schon ziemlich forscht sowas aber
nicht lang oder irgendwann sagt man sich
passt ja mal eben so ach quatsch
wirklich ja aha nein kein Wunder
sozusagen wie stark das Regime unter
Druck steht naja die Kritik ist ja
offensichtlich auch gehört worden
zumindest so laut dass man sie nicht
ignorieren kann insofern
das Problem ist dass die Kritik dann
gehört wurde und auch was passiert ist
ungefähr vor fünf sechs sieben Jahren da
stand auch Katar außenpolitisch unter
Druck weil die anderen Golfstaaten
angeführt von Saudi-Arabien Katar die
haben die Grenzen geschlossen zu Katar
die haben also gab es Feindseligkeiten
und plötzlich zeigten sich reformwillig
und haben sich so den Westen zugeneigt
und die Kritik ernst genommen wir waren
da wir haben mit den höchsten Politikern
dort gesprochen die haben größere Form
versprochen und dann gab es sie auch
allerdings zu wenig zu spät einige
wenige kommen jetzt in den Genuss dieser
Reform aber die vielen 100.000 Millionen
von Wanderarbeitern die vorher gelitten
haben die vielleicht gestorben sind
deren Hinterbliebene jetzt in bitterster
Armut sind so dass die Kinder nicht in
die Schule gehen können dass da also
wieder eine neue Generation von ja wann
das Sklaven sozusagen heranwächst das
ist Schuld der katharis die sich einfach
nicht dazu durchringen können und nicht
wollen wegen des Geldes weil es schön
billig ist kommen wir auch das Ändern
okay bleiben wir einmal noch bei der PR
Maschinerie und bei den Fans frau Klein
würden sie hinfliegen und zwar nicht
bezahlt von den cataris sondern selber
als Politikerin selbst bezahlt
also ich fand die Entscheidung immer
schon schwierig dass die WM an Katar
ging sie ist jetzt nun mal so wie sie
ist ich bin jetzt kein Vollblut
Fußballfan deswegen würde ich sowieso
nicht hinfahren aber wichtig ist ja
jetzt in der ganzen Debatte dass wir
nicht unfair gegenüber den Spielern sind
also die bereit sich vor die haben hart
trainiert die freuen sich auch auf die
WM und auf die Fußballfans freuen sich
auf die WM also grundsätzlich dass wir
da eine gute Stimmung haben dass wir
unsere Nationalmannschaft anfeuern und
Spaß am Spiel haben am Sport haben das
finde ich gut und wichtig selber würde
ich da auf jeden Fall nicht hinfahren
und kritisiere auch die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen die da
passiert sind und die Frauenrechte sind
auch ein Punkt wichtiges Thema dass sie
ansprechen das kommt teilweise in der
Diskussion ein bisschen zu kurz wir
sprechen auch aus gutem Grund sehr viel
über die Arbeiter und das ist auch
richtig so auch
lgbtq-rechte sexuelle Minderheiten aber
auch Frau sexuelle absolut das nimmt mir
noch so ein bisschen wenig Raum ein in
der Debatte grundsätzlich was da
passiert und da müssen wir eben auch
drauf schauen dass die Fans geschützt
werden gerade Homosexuelle Fans und auch
Sportler das ihre Einstellung ist ja gar
nicht so weit weg von ihrer These heute
abend Herr reif warum man sich noch auf
die WM freuen darf
es wird Fußball gespielt werden und ich
verstehe jeden der sagt pass auf das ist
mir alles zu viel das ist nicht mehr
mein Fußball das will ich nicht gucken
ist völlig in Ordnung nur ich bin kein
schlechter Mensch wenn ich mir Spiele
angucken werde wenn Sie mir wenn wir
irgendjemand und deswegen in meinem
Alter ist man dann eher doch glaube ich
pragmatischer wenn mir irgendjemand
garantieren kann das ist einem Arbeiter
einer Frau einem homosexuellen nach die
Welt dieser WM besser gehen oder danach
besser gehen wird wenn ich es
boykottiere bin ich sofort dabei mein
Ehrenwort bin ich sofort dabei
ich glaube allerdings dass jetzt über
Boykott zu reden das ist mir auch ein
bisschen zu wohlfalt zu weinen ich habe
das Gefühl Menschen sitzen hier im
warmen Sessel und sagen so jetzt wollen
wir mal sehen wie unsere Spieler da
reagiert aber ich habe ein Zeichen sehen
also was sie sollen Doppelpass spielen
und danach sofort ein Zeichen setzen die
sollen sich äußern wenn sie was zu sagen
haben und wenn sie informiert sind ich
hoffe dass der DFB und die nach allem
was ich so gehört habe machen sie das
das sieht die Spieler darüber
informieren was sie dort erwartet nur
dass wir uns hier hinsetzen im Baumesse
damit wir uns wohler fühlen und sagen so
macht das mal da ich will wollen aber
schon mal sehen dass ihr da richtig mal
Flagge zeigt das ist mir ein bisschen zu
billig aber wer sagt denn das wer
forderten
viele viele
also ich habe auch Leute unterhalten die
sagen sie werden sich kein einziges
Spiel sie werden die Spiele gucken sie
werden alternativ Geschichten in Kneipen
machen und dann frage ich sag mal aber
die deutschen Spiele na gut die gucke
ich mir an wir sind das ist mir
es ist aber eine einfache Debatte also
viel wichtiger ist es doch jetzt darüber
zu reden welche Rolle die FIFA da
gespielt haben sie eben einfach die
Spieler dazu zwingt wie auch schon im
Winter der das Internationale Olympische
Komitee Athleten dazu gezwungen hat
unter solchen Bedingungen ihr Bestes zu
geben das ist einfach eine Schweinerei
und deswegen sollte nie wieder so eine
mega-sportveranstaltung wie die WM an so
ein Land vergeben werden
die Frage von Herr ralf war ja sehr
spannend oder die Aussage wenn mir
jemand versichern kann dass ein
Menschenleben gerettet wird oder aus
einem Menschen besser geht in Katar dann
würde ich sofort das nicht schauen und
boykottieren aber das ist ja der Punkt
das heißt sie sagen auch ein Boykott
bringt jetzt nichts nein sehr viel zu
spät auch ja also wir hatten zum
Beispiel auch im Bundestag tatsächlich
eine Anhörung zu diesem Thema im
Frühjahr Sommer um den Dreh und da haben
wir Experten eingeladen die auch sehr
klar gesagt haben es ist naiv zu glauben
dass dadurch dem
digitalisierungsprozesse eintreten durch
wenn man das jetzt boykottiert oder wenn
man sich verspricht das durch so eine
wm-demokratieprozesse in Gang gestartet
werden nur richtig ist aber dass wir
gleichzeitig die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen ja ansprechen
und thematisieren und grundsätzlich wenn
Sportler auch Signale senden Zeichen
setzen finde ich das
beispielsweise die Spieler die
Regenbogenfahne tragen würden oder die
Flagge tragen würden warum nicht also
Sport und Fußball ist doch auch
Botschafter für Toleranz und
Völkerverständigung und grundsätzlich
finde ich das richtig und wenn es wenn
es Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt für die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und fünf
stärkeres Bewusstsein führt insbesondere
in der Öffentlichkeit dass das nicht in
Ordnung ist was da passiert und dadurch
auch der Druck aufgebaut wird auf das
Regime dann ist das richtig also die
europäischen Teilnehmer haben sich ja
gar nicht dass die Kapitäne eine eine
bunte nicht die Regenbogen fand die
reine Leere ist es nicht aber sie haben
sich geeinigt auf eine eine
Kapitänsbinde die ein Zeichen zuschauen
so das aber wir sind das sind so so
ritualisierte Dinge da ja es ist gut wir
nehmen zur Kenntnis ist gut das wird es
nicht sein nur nicht hin zu fahren und
nichts mehr zu tun jetzt wieder ich war
mal hatte Gelegenheit und drei Tage in
Nordkorea zu verbringen
und da stellt sich nicht die Frage bei
Nordkorea Boykott oder nicht zu und da
kommt niemand rein und die sind für sich
ich habe dort gesehen wie es Menschen
geht also deswegen ist mir jede
Möglichkeit irgendwo hinzufahren ja ich
würde nach al Journalist sofort nach
Katar fahren sofort nur wir machen es
von hier mit BTV ich würde sofort fahren
weil nicht in der Hoffnung dass ich
alles entdecke was es zu entdecken gibt
aber ein paar Dinge selber zu sehen ich
halte das für wichtig
vor Ort überhaupt freiberichten und das
wird auch an ihnen liegen nach unseren
Standards frei berichten können aber es
wird Freiräume geben und die geht es zu
nutzen so gut es
und in den schönen Glitzer Gegenden
die ersten Journalisten die jetzt schon
da sind gesagt sie kommt kaum noch an
die Arbeit daran oder an die Frauen oder
an irgendwelche anderen weil die schon
eingeschüchtert sind so in Katar sie
auch ein Überwachungsstaat das heißt
jeder WhatsApp Post und so weiter wird
da von den Behörden noch mit gelesen
aber was wäre die Option nicht hinfahren
als Journalist umso wichtiger dass
Journalisten hinfahren und wir haben ja
gerade am Anfang gesagt wenn Sie darüber
berichten dass sie nicht berichten
dürfen damit jeden Tag möchte ich das
Hören mal sehen wie der Druck auf die
Kataris wie sie da reagiert die sind
sehr sensibel in ihren Dingen und schlau
wenn die merken du pass auf dass das
geht gerade ganz schief diese WM wird
doch nicht wie er Infantino sagte die
beste aller Zeiten sondern hier geht was
richtig den Bach runter ist lassen sie
mir meine naive Sichtweise dass man
etwas schrittchenweise bewirken kann und
wie gesagt wenn es einem nur besser geht
danach hat es sich hat es schon Sinn
gemacht jetzt nicht zu Boykott
dass die Vergabe damals das war eine
große Chance zu einem solchen Zeitpunkt
zu sagen pass auf es gibt diese und
diese Kriterien und darunter springt
niemand wer da drunter springt auch nur
in einem Punkt ist raus aus der
Bewerbung das war die mit Abstand
schlechteste Bewerbung jeder sagt das
und der erzählt der der Platte also das
vor dem Kuvert gezogen hat der war ja
selber entsetzt
so mal davon abgesehen ob er nicht
vorher schon ich würde sagen wir machen
hier heute schon mal den fragen denn es
ist wichtig wie Herr reif sagt dass man
berichten muss und reden muss darüber
was in Katar passiert und da haben sie
ja michaelske heute eine These
mitgebracht damit wir heute genau das
machen und darüber berichten wie es vor
Ort ist also die cataris aber auch die
FIFA hat jetzt über zehn Jahre Zeit zu
zeigen dass es ihnen auch wirklich ernst
ist mit den Ankündigungen der Sport wird
was Gutes bewirken für die Menschen was
Gutes bewirken jetzt ist da über zehn
Jahre nicht viel passiert ein paar
Reform ja das muss man auf anerkennen
das ist sehr gut aber nicht weitreichend
genug so jetzt haben wir mit wir mal
durch die Kritiker oder die
Zivilgesellschaft die NGOs
FIFA und Katar ein
rettungsring-angeboten um die den Ruf
noch zu retten und zwar ist es die
wirklich bescheidene Forderung ein
entschädigungsform oder ein
zahlungsfonds für die Hinterbliebenen
der Arbeiter die bitterarm in Nepal und
Bangladesch leben so ein einzurichten
und diesen Rettungsring haben jetzt die
cataris
verachtend beiseite geschoben indem sie
gestern gesagt haben nee machen wir
nicht wir müssen auch gar nicht welche
alles gestorben ist was übrigens eine
Lüge ist denn es ist alles ganz gut
dokumentiert in Katar wer da waren wie
wo war aber warum hat Katar das nicht
gemacht weil das Bild von Katar ist den
ja schon wichtig in der Öffentlichkeit
warum hat Katar das nicht gemacht wir
sehen in den letzten Tagen eine
Veränderung im Verhalten Katars äh nennt
sie Feser die Innenministerin hat am
Wochenende die Menschenrechtssituation
in Katar kritisiert und daraufhin haben
die katharis die Situation eskaliert
indem sie den deutschen Botschafter
einberufen haben das ist eine
riesengroße Maßnahme sowas zu machen das
macht man eigentlich kaum das heißt sie
sind jetzt Forscher sie werden auch
unterstützt in ihrer in ihrem Handeln in
ihren Aussagen von den umliegenden
Staaten also gab es wohl auch Absprachen
wie wir lassen uns jetzt ist nichts mehr
gefallen die können Sie WM eh nicht mehr
wegnehmen und wir sprechen jetzt zu
unseren eigenen Leuten die uns
unterstützen und ja Nancy Feser fuhr
dahin und ist ein paar Stunden da
gewesen und hat gleich vor die Kamera
sich gestellten gesagt ne ist eigentlich
alles ganz gut also wie kommt denn das
zustande
und dann eben am Nachmittag diese
Pressekonferenz des Arbeitsministers wo
er einfach diese ja diesen Rettungsring
zahlungsfonds in die Mülltonne getreten
hat das ist forsch ja das ist den jetzt
mittlerweile egal Widerruf ist aber Frau
klein da muss man ja dann schon fragen
was wäre denn die rote Linie weswegen
man doch noch sagen muss es geht einfach
nicht mehr
also ich finde dieses Beispiel schon
ziemlich 30 ich sehe das genauso und
Entschädigungsfonds ist schon das
Minister was man aufsetzen müsste gerade
für die Familien für die Angehörigen die
Menschen verloren haben
grundsätzlich ist das also es ist ja
keine politische Entscheidung gewesen
dieser Entscheidung der WM-Vergabe
Politik ist aber das genau zu
problematisieren und das zu
thematisieren insofern finde ich es
falsch was das was Sigmar Gabriel da
gemacht hat dass er sozusagen die Dinge
versucht zu beschwichtigen dass das ist
genau das falsche Signal unsere Aufgabe
heißt es ja so viele SPD und ehemalige
SPD-Politiker haben gute Kontakte zur
autorisiert autoritären Regime das gibt
mir ein bisschen zu denken aber
unabhängig davon ist es einfach Aufgabe
der Politik da sehr klar auch drauf zu
achten die Dinge zu benennen wie sie
sind und dann auch bei den
entsprechenden Gesprächen dann auf
diplomatischer Ebene die Dinge
anzusprechen die Frage die er bleibt
Herr reif ist was sprechen sich die
katharis denn eigentlich von der WM also
bislang kriegen sie jetzt auch nicht so
viel Beifall dafür
naja schon ist es
nebenagegeschichte
von Paris St Germain und und
rein und mir hatten Katar immer gesagt
gefragt hat immer aber das ist so ihr
gewinnt die Champions League trotzdem
nicht und so und dann sagte der wenn man
wie viel wir zahlen müssten um die
Aufmerksamkeit und diese diese
Imagekampagne laufen zu lassen wenn wir
das das 10 15 20-fache und da ist das
für uns Taschengeld was wir in in die in
Paris reinstecken diese WM kostet ein
Vermögen das können sich andere Länder
nicht leisten können darüber wird man
nach dieser WM auch noch mal reden
können mir wäre es auch lieber es würden
nur die guten die WMS kriegen aber es
wird schwer es wird es wird sehr schwer
weil sie werden sehen normale normale
Länder die demokratische Strukturen
haben wo Menschen auch sagen nee weißt
du Olympische Spiele München Olympische
Spiele Oslo ein Sport verrücktes machen
wir nicht für das Geld was ihr da wollt
und dieses alles hier auf dem Kopf
stellt danke nein so dann kommen die
katharis und sagen aber was ihr wollt
acht Stadien 10 wie wir es mit 12 sie
überhaupt kein Problem das wird ein
Problem werden auf auf lange Sicht aber
das lassen wir mal die FIFA
also die katharis brauchen
außenpolitisch in ihrer Region eine eine
Stellung die sie ein bisschen
unantastbar macht Anlehnung an den
Westen damit ihre Nachbarn die sie
boykottiert haben das hat sich oder
völlig isoliert haben das hat sich ja
jetzt aufgelöst so langsam
also wenn sich ein bisschen auch nur ein
bisschen ändert und wenn sie doch
begreifen während dieser WM der Druck
ist so groß und das Image ist nicht so
wie wir es wollten und dann wird die
Frage sein wie reagieren die anderen
Länder weil da habe ich ja emiratet die
jetzt diplomatische Beziehung mit Israel
aufgenommen habe ich halte das für für
für Schritte aber Kata wir zeigen müssen
wo sie hin wo sie wirklich hin wollen
was sie aus dieser WM am Ende für sich
rausholen irgendwo wenn Sie eine
kostenlosen Rechnung
machen da bin ich bin ich bin ich
ziemlich sicher
Elli sind ja nicht nur deutsche sondern
auch Engländer wie blickt England denn
auf die WM ja auch ähnlich ich glaube
wir sehen das in der westlichen Welt
alle so ich bezweifle nur dass der Rest
der Welt das genauso sieht wie wir also
ich alles was wir gesagt haben ist
vollkommen zu Recht alles muss auch
kritisiert werden viel zu spät alles
klar übrigens lässt sich glaube ich FC
Bayern auch Sponsoren von Katar und
Pflicht regelmäßig dort ins Camp also
ein bisschen Doppelmoral eine eigene
Nase sollten uns auch mal fassen aber
ich glaube wir sehen das ich glaube
Katar für gewissen Abschluss Image
stehen Herr Reifert vollkommen Recht für
die spielt Geld keine Rolle und wir
sehen es so wie wir es hier sehen wie
wir sie diskutiert haben aber der Rest
der Welt glaube ich nicht aber das
imageding ist ja auch wenn wir hier auch
heimlicher als gezuckert haben ist ja
auch ein Risiko für Katar das muss man
ja ganz klar sagen weil wenn die
Journalisten jetzt vor Ort doch
durchkommen und richtig berichten könnte
es dann auch eine Zeit der Hoffnung
werden weil viel mehr darüber gezeigt
wird doch noch vielleicht positiv es
kommt darauf an ob dann diese
Berichterstattung von den Reformkräften
innerhalb Katars genutzt werden kann ja
denn Katar das ist ja auch nicht kein
homogene Geschichte das sind zwar nur
200 300.000 Katara alle anderen 1,9
Millionen oder zwei Millionen sind
Wanderarbeiter
aber da möchte jeder auch das größte
Stück vom Kuchen haben es gibt ja auch
andere Familien die vielleicht auch gern
mal den Emir stellen wollen der der
Großvater von dem hier der hat sich das
auch irgendwann mal mit einem Putsch
angeeignet also insofern ist es ganz
interessant zu sehen wer da raus
profitieren kann gibt sind die
Konservativen diejenigen die daraus
siegreich hervorgehen als als ich ein
kataver da haben wir mit Menschen
gesprochen die Waren an englischen
amerikanischen Universitäten und die
Sprachen wie auch ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter und andere wieder
die waren doch sehr sehr sehr sehr
traditionell und sehr religiös das war
eine ganz andere Atmosphäre und diese
Kräfte spielen da in dem Land natürlich
und ziehen an allen Ecken und Enden und
zusammenfassend ist es eine
Aufbruchstimmung vor Ort kann man sagen
dass vielleicht was in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten sich ändern wird
ich glaube wenig also das was wir jetzt
in den letzten Tagen eben gesehen haben
das ist ja eher ein Rückschritt und auch
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
regelmäßig in Katar sind und die
Experten sind in dieser Region die haben
eigentlich seit ungefähr ein oder zwei
Jahren doch schon Rückschritte
wahrgenommen also jetzt wo es so nah
dran ist und vielleicht auch weil sie
merken oh die Deutschen und die anderen
die sind ja jetzt plötzlich abhängig von
unserem Erdgas das wollen die haben
vorher wollten wir das ja alles gar
nicht ja und plötzlich sind das die
großen Leute und die können top-dollar
verlangen für ein bisschen Erdgas und
unser Wirtschaftsminister ein grüner der
die Menschenrechte so groß in die
Trampel mit reingeschrieben hat macht
einen tiefen Diener das ist die Realität
Menschenrecht ist ein gutes Stichwort
herr Scholz ist ja auch in China und
tritt dafür die Menschenrechte ein frau
Klein sind hier denn das Maß aller Dinge
weil hier wurde es gerade schon
angesprochen als Beispiel mit Herr
Habeck da haben sie sehr gut die
Moderationen vorweggenommen sind wir das
Maß aller Dinge wie verhalten wir uns
dann eigentlich
naja so zunächst mal ist festzustellen
dass Freiheit in Demokratie nicht
selbstverständlich sind und wie ein
hohes Maß an Freiheit und Demokratie
Gott sei Dank haben als aber nicht in
jedem Land so aussieht wie bei uns
grundsätzlich sind wir natürlich als
starker Handelspartner auch stark im
Auftreten und können durchaus auch ein
bisschen
die Dinge benennen wie sie sind im
Ausland man sollte nicht zu sehr ich
sage jetzt mal mit dem gestreckten
Zeigefinger mit dem moralischen
Zeigefinger auftreten das ist auch klar
am Ende des Tages geht es darum ein
gutes Verständnis miteinander zu finden
aber eben nicht auf Kosten der Menschen
die im Ausland darunter leiden durch
Menschen aber wenn man auf die Reise von
Herrn Harbeck blickt dann ist ja schon
die Frage müssen wir uns ehrlich machen
und es geht gar nicht mehr ohne diese
Länder also können wir gar nicht mehr
nur mit demokratischen Ländern arbeiten
naja wir haben ja nie nur mit
demokratischen Ländern gearbeitet dass
das wäre ja auch falsch dazu dargestellt
Ukraine Konflikt schaut wenn man Frau
bärbock zuhört als Außenministerin da
erscheint ja eigentlich das Ziel zu sein
dass wir bald nur noch mit also für mich
erscheint das Ziel zu sein der aktuellen
Ampel das ist ja natürlich unser alles
aller Ziel dass wir Demokratie und
Freiheit nach draußen tragen und dass
das überall zum Standard wird das ist
doch ganz klar aber die Frage wir lügen
uns doch jetzt ein vor das ist doch
völliger Utopie das ist erinnert mich so
ein bisschen an wir verteidigen unsere
Freiheit am Hindukusch das ist genauso
ein Schwachsinn gewesen also wir können
doch nicht allen Ernstes hingehen und
Herr Scholz muss natürlich hinfahren
weil wir abhängig sind von China wir
haben uns von allen abhängig gemacht und
das wird auch mein Thema nachher sein
wir machen uns ja ständig abhängig von
anderen und lernen aus Fehlern gar nicht
die sagen ja man soll den Zeigefinger
zeigen aber wir stehen natürlich für
Freiheit und Demokratie das ist unsere
ganz zentrale und wichtig war sind ja
auch die Bilder die gesendet werden der
den Kotau den Sie angesprochen haben den
Habeck da gemacht hat das war das ist
glaube ich nicht so gut angekommen
insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund der
Menschenrechtsverletzungen die da
stattgefunden haben und darum geht es
natürlich auch welche Botschaften senden
wir eigentlich aus wir aber gucken wir
doch mal jetzt die Reise von Herrn
Scholz nach China an ja mit wem fährt er
denn dahin also wie gesagt die
Ampelkoalition die hat sich die
Menschenrechte in die Ampel ihres
Koalitionsvertrags geschrieben so jetzt
fährt er dahin nur mit
Wirtschaftsvertretern nicht mit
irgendwelchen Menschen die chinesische
Wurzeln haben und die das Land verlassen
mussten zum Beispiel kein Vertreter der
Uiguren die wahnsinnig unterdrückt
werden in Ching Chang das heißt die
Frage ist doch macht Scholz den gleichen
Fehler den die Regierungen vorher
gemacht haben mit Russland die Frage ist
also ob es eine Mogelpackung ist der
Regierung mit den Menschenrecht eine
Mogelpackung oder rationalisieren sie
das Verhältnis zu China und reden sich
jetzt ein wie ich jetzt auch schon
wieder von politischen Beratern gehört
habe ja der Ski ist eigentlich ein ganz
vernünftiger Mensch das sind dieselben
Leute die 2014 gesagt haben ja könnte
das eigentlich ein ganz vernünftiger
Mensch und Steinmeier hat damit dann und
und und Frau Merkel auch die haben dann
den total Ausverkauf unserer Energie
weiter betrieben an Russland machen wir
jetzt denselben Fehler und wir überhaupt
nur mit vernünftigen Menschen handeln
können nein wir können nicht nur mit
vernünftigen Menschen handeln das ist ja
auch in jeder Nachbarschaft so aber wir
müssen für die Menschenrechte eintreten
denn wenn wir es nicht tun dann stolpern
wir von einem Schlamassel zum anderen
und das haben wir eben an Russland
gesehen jetzt ist es billig und die
Industrie freut sich wenn Sie jetzt noch
mehr Fabriken und noch mehr Handel
treiben kann mit China und der
Verbraucher freut sich dass das
Plastikspielzeug immer noch so schön
billig ist aber am Ende des Tages wird
die Rechnung so hoch sein wir haben die
hohe Rechnung jetzt zu bezahlen in unter
dem Aspekt Russland und das werden wir
irgendwann mit China genauso und
wahrscheinlich noch bitterer Erleben der
verfassungsschef verfassungsschutzchef
halten Wangen hat zu Recht gesagt
Russland ist das Sturm China ist der
Klimawandel also die Reise kommt zu
einer Unzeit er macht sie alleine ohne
die Europäer mit denen er viel mächtige
auftreten könnte und
also was ich gelesen habe in einem
Gastkommentar von Scholz der im
Politiker erschienen ist heute hat er
auch gar nicht vor wirklich prominent
die Menschenrechte dort anzusprechen wir
fordern die Menschenrechte müssen
mindestens so prominent angesprochen
werden wie die Wirtschaft dann muss man
ja fast sagen Herr reif dann waren ja
auch die Olympischen Spiele in China
wenn man jetzt mit der moralischen
Brille schaut auch ein Fehler dann ist
ja eigentlich da können wir jetzt ja
eigentlich ein riesige Liste aufmachen
so ist es und die die wird nicht kleiner
werden das ist ja das was ich vorhin
dachte ich habe
92 waren die Olympischen Winterspiele in
Lillehammer das waren die in Norwegen
wenn die schönsten Winterspiele je
gesehen habe
angemessene Größe da wurde das
ausgegeben was auch Sinn macht dann
wurden Sportstätten geschaffen die
weiter danach nachhaltig verwendet
wurden so eine sportverrücktere Nation
als Norwegen gibt es nicht gar nicht so
lange her Oslo sollte wieder
Winterspiele kriegen weil ich vorhin
sagte sie haben gesagt mit den Vorgaben
die ihr wollt mit dem mit diesem
Gigantismus danke sagen die norwegit
wollen wir nicht das heißt vernünftige
Menschen die lassen sie schlafen genau
ist dieser Gigantismus Herr reif für
Menschen die nicht so
die Staaten sind die schönste Stadt die
ich je gesehen habe unfassbar Schönberg
architektonisch aber die hätte ich gerne
im Modell und damit hatte sich was wegen
Kata die Liga dort gehen 150 Menschen zu
einem Spiel das ist aber schon viel und
dann machst du 18 12 solche Stadien da
müsst die die Leute die am Hebel dann
sitzen wenn wir jetzt auf Sport wieder
gehen also FIFA die muss sagen pass auf
nee das das geht nicht oder ihr sagt mir
wie ihr die dann wieder abbauen könnt
dann werden die aber dafür wenn ich
solche schönen Stadien machen das ist
eine Falle in der sie heute nicht mehr
rauskommen werden und das wird schwierig
dann nur noch mit vernünftigen
Anbietern Anfragen Bewerbern umzugehen
wie ist das passiert dass der
Gigantismus im Sport mehr zählt als die
Leidenschaft wie Sie es gerade zum
Beispiel aus Norwegen angesprochen haben
die FIFA ist ein ein eine
Geldeinnahme
geldvermehrungsgeldverteilungsmaschine
geworden
ich habe lange Zürich gelebt die das
FIFA Gebäude ich habe von erfrischender
Selbstironie das ist also fünf Stoff
vier Stockwerke sind unter der Erde und
ein Stockwerk über der Erde dort
arbeiten
unheimlich engagierte gute Leute die die
FIFA ist nicht nur Infantino und die
vergebe an Kata die tolle Sache machen
die die Jugendfußball weltweit
unterstützen Frauenfußball alles gut nur
oben sitzt eine Clique die sich selber
um sich selber dreht und um und das das
funktioniert weil es funktioniert das
der Stimme wenn irgendjemand kommen
würde und würde sagen pass auf Schluss
aus aber das ist eine spannende Frage
warum das funktioniert weil zum Beispiel
realisiert Fußballfeld
sie als Fußballfan macht ihnen das denn
nicht weniger Lust auf Fußball
eigentlich
wir haben ja vorhin gesagt ich bin noch
die Stimmung gespannt es werden die
schönsten Spiele aller Zeiten da wird
doch keine Stimmen aufkommen das soll
lächerlich also erstmal mit
Geräuschkulissen dafür sorgen
wahrscheinlich eine super Stimmung hast
jetzt 50 holländische Fans eingekauft
natürlich ist es keine WM wie wie wir
sie malen im Leben aber trotzdem müssen
wir unsere Leute unterstützen unsere
Sportler ja das sollte uns ja nicht
sozusagen
ihr macht aber nach jedem Tor will ich
aber sehen dass ihr Zeichen setzt das
ist Überforderung und das ist unredlich
das heißt hier am Tisch wenn man es mal
zusammenfasst keiner wird boykottiert
keiner ist für den Boykott
so viel Einigkeit hatten wir selten bei
8:15 was ganz schönes wir gehen eine
ganz kurz Unterbrechungen sind dann
zurück
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
totalitär was sie davon
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Broder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst dass wir zu wenig
Stadt haben wir haben zu viel Staaten
wenn die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos
verkaufen das funktioniert nicht dann
ist mit Wohlstand oder ist alles Essig
als freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen unser Land fordert dann müsst
ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch was
machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den wir reden soll
[Musik]
nach Katar blicken wir innenpolitisch
und schauen mal was Anthony Robert Lee
zu sagen hat über die Ernährung in
Deutschland und wie es eigentlich um die
steht ja harter cut aber ich bin
enttäuscht dass ich überhaupt über
dieses Thema sprechen muss und zwar geht
es mir hauptsächlich darum dass wir uns
jeden Tag über Kosten von Energie Strom
und Gas unterhalten und vergessen dabei
die wichtigste Energie überhaupt die
Landwirte hunderttausende noch 200.000
knapp in Deutschland jeden Tag für uns
produzieren aus Sonne Erde und ein
unfassbaren Know-how und uns jeden Tag
versorgen und genau das steht auf dem
Spiel
Europa aber auch Deutschland forciert
immer mehr Abkommen mit Ländern wie
Südamerika das Merkur so Abkommen oder
ceta Abkommen was jetzt neulich erst
beschlossen wurde mit Kanada wir
importieren Ware die nicht ansatzweise
unsere Standards hat und wir reden den
ganzen Tag von Klimaschutz Artenschutz
wir reden von Kreislaufwirtschaft und
aus Gegenteil passiert jeden Tag sterben
in Deutschland
Hilfe und die kommen niemals wieder und
wir haben nichts gelernt aus der
Abhängigkeit zum Beispiel aus Russland
weil wenn diese Energiequellen also die
Nahrung die wir zu uns nehmen nicht mehr
zu uns herkommen kann haben wir einen
massives Problem und was bedeutet das
wenn man das jetzt wirklich
zusammenfasst für unser Land naja dass
wir uns wieder mal in einer Abhängigkeit
begeben von Ländern wir haben gerade
über autokarten gesprochen gucken Sie
mal wie viele wie viele Ware hier aus
China kommt wir importierend Ware im
Wert von 90 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr aus
173 Ländern und das war 1990 nicht so
1990 hatten wir 100% Autarkie da konnten
wir zu 100% selbst versorgen wir haben
ein Selbstversorgungsgrad aktuell von
Gemüse und Obst von gerade mal 30
Prozent wir hatten vor drei Jahren bei
Weizen ein Selbstversorgungsgrad von
110%. das wird von der politischen Seite
kritisiert dass wir damit zu viel haben
also man muss auch froh sein dass man
eine Reserve hat von einem Prozent das
sehr lächerlich und wir sehen es jetzt
die zugespitzt wir können uns nicht mehr
selbst ernähren also wir werden uns wir
könnten uns selbst ernähren wenn wir
politischen
Rückendeckung hätten man würde uns die
Hand Fesseln lösen weil das unehrlich
und die Doppelmoral an der ganzen Nummer
ist ja dass wir hier
wohlstandards die vollkommen zu Recht
eingeführt werden dass mich hier keiner
falsch versteht nur diese Standards
diese Sozialstaaten 12 Euro Mindestlohn
oder die Umweltstandards die wir zurecht
haben die hat doch nicht Einsatzweise
jemand in Südamerika in China oder in
Australien die EU hat einen Abkommen mit
Australien gerade beschlossen die ich
Australien haben gesagt wir werden eure
Standard sich erfüllen können das machen
wir auch nicht da die EU trotzdem gesagt
dann unterschreiben aber trotzdem
Lösungsansatz die Lösungsansatz ist ja
dass wir erstmal sagen wir importieren
nur Ware die auch unsere Standards hat
das ist doch beim Auto vollkommen normal
wenn der Japaner der Amerikaner ein Auto
importiert dann muss das die Standards
haben die unsere
Straßenverkehrszulassungsordnung zu sie
ist zulässt und nichts anderes oder wenn
ich einen Stecker importier aus China
hat er ein
Verbraucher werden also wie viel mehr
würde es mich dann kosten weil
grundsätzlich glaube ich ganz sicher das
sagt ja sogar er hält sie mir da hat er
sogar ausnahmsweise mal recht das ist im
im mittelfristigen Bereich günstiger
wird und wir müssen uns aber auch davon
wegmachen nur weil es ein Cent günstiger
ist machen wir das wir haben ein
Oligopol mit den vier mächtigen
Lebensmittel einsenden die 90% in
Deutschland kontrollieren die bestimmen
erstmal was wir bekommen wir sind das
einzige Gewerk in Deutschland was kein
Preisschild an seiner Leistung machen
kann wir müssen das nehmen was Edeka
Aldi und Co uns anbietet und da geht es
um Centbeträge zum Beispiel importieren
wir dann Kirschen aus der Türkei
Kirschen und zwar zu Erntezeit wenn wir
hier Kirschen haben das gleiche hatten
wir bei Erdbeeren das wird ja auch in
den Medien ab und zu mal wenigstens
berichtet wir haben Erdbeerbauern die
haben die beste Ernte hingestellt so
nachhaltig wie es irgendwie nur geht und
haben die dann abgemolzt und dann
gegrobert also den Boden bearbeitet und
dann meist den gepflanzt wir haben also
mehr essensverschwendung geht ja gar
nicht ich meine wir die meisten pro Tag
30.000 Tonnen pro Tag in Deutschland
Lebensmittel weg aber die größte
essenverschwendung findet ihr auf den
Feldern statt das ist ja der Skandal
einer ganz normal und da müssen wir
wirklich Wache ein waches Auge haben
ansonsten wir haben es jetzt gesehen wir
haben Abkommen mit Argentinien forciert
habe ich gerade schon erwähnt
argentinien hat jetzt nichts mehr
exportiert weil die eine Missernte
hatten die einmal Trockenheit ohne Ende
Australien Ausgleiche Australien hatten
schwere Überschwemmung die kommen zu 80%
gar nicht die Felder drauf um jetzt die
sind ja jetzt bald in der Ernte das
überhaupt zu ernten und wollen wir uns
in die Abhängigkeit begeben wir haben ja
hier eine Politikerin am Tisch die ist
jetzt ja nicht in der Ampel sondern in
der Union CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete aber
der fragt man sich natürlich schon wenn
man Handy so zuhört wie konnte es denn
also weit kommen und was tut die
deutsche Politik jetzt um das zu
verbessern also ich muss vielleicht
erstmal dazu sagen dass ich
Bundestagsabgeordnete für den Wahlkreis
Berlin-Mitte bin das ist wahrscheinlich
einer der Wahlkreise mit dem wenigsten
mit der wenigsten landwirtschaftlichen
Produktion in ganz Deutschland deswegen
dass das nicht mein Schwerpunktthema
aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich
das Argument wirklich so
hundertprozentig Teile was sie gerade
vorgetragen haben denn es ist mir ist es
zu sehr schwarz und weiß also wir sind
ja auch innerhalb der EU wir haben
handeln mit unseren EU-Partnern mit
vielen anderen Ländern und diese
Freihandelsabkommen diese genannt haben
übrigens ceta wollen wir als cdu/csu
unbedingt auf die Tagesordnung des
Deutschen Bundestages bringen das wird
dauernd von der Ampel wieder runter
genommen denn wir versprechen uns eben
genau das dass unter anderem auch diese
Standards eingehalten werden und wir
dazu einer besseren Verbindung kommen
was den Handel angeht aber fakt ist doch
dass diese Abschottung und doch gar
nicht weiter bringt denn diese
Abschottung was was ist also sie
plädieren sozusagen für 100 Prozent ich
habe gesagt wir brauchen wenn überhaupt
war importiert wird dieselben Standards
es kann doch nicht sein dass wir jetzt
allen Ernst aus Südamerika waren
importieren die mit
Pflanzenschutzmitteln behandelt wurde
die bei uns seit 30 Jahren verboten sind
wo es Argentinien Rindfleisch kommt was
mit Wachstumshormonen gefüttert wird was
bei uns seit Jahren vollkommen zu Recht
verboten ist und dann auf Schiffe die
beschwert hierüber fahren und die
fleischware dort Tiefkühl gelagert ist
genauso schwachsinnig wie LNG Gas aus
den USA Herd dafür sind doch diese
Freihandelsabkommen da dass man sich
darüber verständigt was sind die
Standards ja was machen Sie hier nicht
das machen sie als Politiker gar nicht
diese ihn sind die Standards vollkommen
egal ich habe da gerade ausgeführt die
EU sagt Australien ihr müsst Standards
erfüllen wie unsere sagen machen wir
nicht trotzdem wir unterschrieben ceta
genau das gleiche sie glauben noch nicht
allen Ernstes dass die kanadische
Landwirtschaft genauso hochmodern und
genauso professionell läuft und genauso
nachhaltig wie bei uns das ist doch
nicht ernst also Kanada ist schon auf
einem sehr hohen Standard das sehr hohen
Ausrede stellen aber ttip gerade bei
ttip als die Diskussion doch wahr haben
wir doch über chlorhühnchen und so
weiter gesprochen da ging es um
Standards deswegen dieses Argument das
dem das teile ich nicht
Teil der aber das Teil der Bayern
Mitglied aber wir sind ja auch durch die
CDU genau da rein weil man bewusst
irgendwie hier bei uns ein bullerbüh
haben will bei uns muss alles alte schön
Sonnenschein sein was woanders auf der
Welt passiert ist vollkommen egal das
hat übrigens Julia Klöckner uns hier in
Berlin gesagt aber ein ein Fakt ist ja
spannend merkte funktionieren ja nach
Angebot und Nachfrage eigentlich in
jedem Bereich dementsprechend nehmen Sie
mir die Frage nicht übel aber wenn diese
Produkte so viel besser sind warum dann
kauft der Konsument nicht einfach lieber
die Produkte aus Deutschland das kann
ich ihm sagen am Regal endet die Moral
dann müssen wir uns auch mal ehrlich
machen als Bürger das ist nun mal so
aber trotzdem versuchen Sie mal nur als
Beispiel in Supermarkt zu gehen und ein
deutschen Apfel zu finden selbst wenn
sie dann Bio gucken kaufen wollen da
finden sie bio-apfel die kommen aus aus
Peru aus Neuseeland und aus Südafrika
was soll denn daran Bio sein die meisten
Obst und Gemüse etwas bio ist kommt
übrigens aus Spanien was unter
Plastikfolie hergestellt wird Millionär
100.000 hunderte von Hektaren sieht man
aus dem Weltall übrigens und das wird
nur von deutschen
Äpfel teurer sind oder warum
wahrscheinlich sind die ein bisschen
teurer das mag sein aber ich meine ich
gehe jeden Tag einkaufen mit meinen
Kindern also nicht jeden Tag aber jeden
Samstag auf jeden Fall hatte ich mir
frei und ich gucke mir bewusst die
ganzen Preise an es ist ja auch
unheimlich schwer und das ist etwas wir
von Anfang an gefordert haben wir
brauchen eine klare unmissverständliche
Herkunftskennzeichnung der Produkte dass
jeder Bürger hingehen kann sagt okay das
ist drunter und daher dass er die und
die Standards das kaufe ich kaufe ich
nicht wir fragen einmal in der Runde
Herr Ralf achten Sie darauf wo die
Produkte herkommen die Sie einkaufen
nein ich habe ich achte auf eine
Qualität und ich habe irgendwann mal
begriffen das eine Flasche Wein nicht
unter 5 € Kosten kann meine Schwägerin
ist Winzerin und die hat mal gesagt komm
doch mal mit hoch hilfe mein heb mal ein
bisschen so ein Tag nach einer Stunde
habe ich gesagt alle Tassen im Schrank
bei mir kommt der Wein aus der Flasche
danke schön aber da habe ich verstanden
das geht nicht Fleisch Menschen wollen
das ist der da vielleicht wer der Ansatz
nur das mit euch für einen Moment nicht
helfen aber das verbrauche irgendwann
mal begreifen müssen ein Stück Fleisch
das eine Qualität haben soll wie ich sie
meinen gerne anbiete und mir auch geht
nicht unter einem bestimmten Preis und
wenn es dann andere Anbieter gibt das
ist die Krux der freien Marktwirtschaft
und wenn du kein Protektionismus machen
willst wenn du den alles zu machst dann
könnten wir es würden aber auch die
gleichen Standards
und hohe Standards haben sollten das
doch ganz klar im Übrigen gehe ich auch
damit wenn sie sagen wir müssen die
deutsche Landwirtschaft Stärken ganz
klar natürlich aber es passiert nicht
sie können mir glauben genau das
Gegenteil ist der Fall warum machen denn
zehn Betriebe jeden Tag zu in
Deutschland kann ja nicht sein das ist
doch unfassbar und also aber sehen Sie
denn nur die Schuld in der Politik die
Rahmenbedingungen sind von der Politik
gesetzt worden da vollkommen klar
selbstverständlich wir haben und gerade
aktuell ist es so dass natürlich auch
diejenigen die auch gerade Fleisch
einkaufen muss auch ehrlich weil sagen
die bei uns das Schlachten wir kriegen
momentan die absolute Mehrheit an
Schweinen aus Spanien und aus Dänemark
ist auch es hat mir die Regionalität um
mit Nachhaltigkeit ja gar nichts zu tun
aber wir wollen uns ja auch nicht
komplett abschotten angesprochen aber
wir können uns hier mit sicherlich eine
Runde alle auf dieselben Standards ein
aber das passiert nun mal auch nicht und
das ist einfach unehrlich und der Bürger
weiß es nicht der Bürger kann es auch
gar nicht wissen deswegen eine echte
Herkunftskennzeichnung wie ist das
behandelt worden hat dass jemand hier
wohl gesehen dass ich jemals
Umweltstandards und Sozialstandards
gesehen äh das muss doch hier eine Runde
eigentlich jeder verstehen und das
eigentlich mit den Energiekosten gerade
um jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen
anderes Thema reinzuwerfen aber das wäre
mir auch noch mal wichtig zu finden
genauso wie jeden anderen draußen jeden
anderen im Mittelstand es ist gar nicht
tragbar die Milchbauern kriegen aktuell
60 Cent da hätten wir vor zwei Jahren
Luftsprünge gemacht aber trotzdem ist ja
alles andere viel viel teurer geworden
ja aber auch
nehmen Sie zum Beispiel wenn Sie Lego
Batterien haben Strom oder halt Gas
brauchen Sie natürlich als als Wärme für
Schweineställe oder so es ist nicht
bezahlbar und das ist eigentlich
momentan das Problem und andere haben
ein völlig ein Wettbewerbsvorteil in der
die EU schon mal weil
Standards haben das gehört soweit
natürlich auch dazu aber natürlich auch
von Übersee also der selbst der Chinese
der der baut ja gerade 12 24 stöckige
Hochhäuser weil die so ein Bedarf haben
an an Essen also 50 Prozent des globalen
Getreides der Reserve liegt übrigens in
China und die kaufen gerade alles leer
alle Märkte und das ist das was ich sage
wenn wir irgendwann mal abhängig sind
von anderen Ländern und die sagen Brazil
first Australia first dann gucken wir
die Röhre
wenn man aber als erstes Land anfängt
dann macht jeder irgendwann diese
nationalistische Haltung aber ich
verstehe was sie meinen ich finde stark
dass sie dieses plädiere
wir können gerne auf eine Märkte aber
die gleichen Standards also die gleichen
Standards ja für alle Länder wo es
eingefüllt wird darauf können sie ja
auch bestimmt beide einigen und damit
können wir zur These von ihnen frau
Klein jawohl also noch mal ein ganz
harter Themen cut es geht jetzt um das
Thema Bürgergeld das Bürgergeld das
eines der Top Themen im Deutschen im
Bundestag es gab schon eine Reihe von
Debatten in der nächsten Woche steht das
Thema wieder auf der Tagesordnung des
Deutschen Bundestages und ich habe
festgestellt und viele meiner Kollegen
auch ist dass die ampelregierung äußerst
dünnhäutig auf Kritik am Bürgergeld
reagiert um es vielleicht vorweg zu
sagen wir als Union sehen das Bürgergeld
kritisch es ist nicht zielführend es ist
ungerecht und das sendet die völlig
falschen Signale und jetzt könnte man
meinen ja es verwundert nicht unbedingt
dass die opp schon nicht die Meinung der
Regierung teilt was wir aber beobachten
ist das unsere Kritik und auch die
Kritik von anderen in der Öffentlichkeit
moralisch abgewertet wird also da ist
dann ganz schnell die Rede von Hetze und
Populismus sind darauf aufmerksam
gemacht wird dass beispielsweise mit der
bürgergeldreform eine gewisse
Ungerechtigkeit geschaffen wird dass
Menschen die niedriges Einkommen haben
nur noch kaum oder kaum mehr Geld zur
Verfügung haben am Ende des Monats mit
Vollzeitjob als jemand der ein
Bürgergeld bezieht und nicht arbeiten
geht nach Abzug aller Kosten allein
schon das darauf aufmerksam machen wird
kritisiert moralisch abgewertet und als
Hetze gebrandmarkt und ich finde diese
Art von Debatte die da geführt wird also
das gesagt wird das Kritiker nach unten
treten sozial kalt sind ich finde dass
das hilft nicht der Debatte im Gegenteil
wir sollten sachliche Argumente
austauschen und ich finde auch die Ampel
muss sich diese Kritik gefallen lassen
denn am Ende des Tages das fühlen sich
sonst die Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
ihrer Kritik vielleicht nicht gehört im
Deutschen Bundestag absolut dafür ist
viel nach auch da habe ich halt wie
sehen Sie das denn ist das Bürgergeld
unfair ist es ungerecht wie stehen Sie
dazu also ich kann da politisch nichts
dazu sagen es ist gar nicht mein Mandat
als Menschenrechtler aber trotzdem kann
ich doch sagen wir sind eines der
reichsten Länder der Welt und es gibt in
Deutschland so eine große Armut dass die
Tafeln die auf einer freiwilligen Hilfe
basieren gar nicht mehr hinterher kommen
so
das kann man sich doch nicht mehr
leisten das heißt also wie wollen wir
die Menschen weiter ernähren wie wollen
wir Ihnen ob das es gibt auf 500.000
freie Jobs aktuell in Deutschland 1,9
Millionen jetzt schon Stellen 1,9
Millionen deswegen sagen wir ja dass wir
aber da sind auch befristete drunter und
Mangel haben ja aber Fakt dass sie sind
offen und wir haben Arbeitskräftemangel
überall und deswegen ist genau das ja
das falsche Signal jetzt sollte es doch
oberste Priorität sein die Menschen
wieder stärker in die Jobs zu bekommen
die Beratung zu verbessern das was die
Ampel aber macht ist da die Mittel zu
kürzen in der Beratung übrigens haben
die haben sie genau das gerade gemacht
was ich kritisiert habe sie haben das
auch so eine soziale moralische Ebene
gezogen als ob wir sozusagen mit unserer
Kritik am Bürgergeld nicht möchten dass
die Menschen sozial abgesichert sind
ganz im Gegenteil der argumentiere
also da ist die soziale Not wenn die
Menschen auf Tafeln sind schon so weit
dass es einen Menschen recht betrifft
nämlich ein Menschenrecht auf Ernährung
auf Gesundheit und ein Menschenrecht
auch auf wohnen vielleicht finden wir
deinen Mittelweg frau Klein sie sind ja
Berlin Mitte das haben sie heute auch
schon der Sendung gesagt
wie teuer ist in Berlin Mitte aktuell
eine Wohnung und super teuer super teuer
das heißt wie viele Aufstocker wird es
dann auch in Zukunft geben bei den Jobs
ist das vielleicht das Problem was
eigentlich die Ampel angehen muss
also das mietenthema ist tatsächlich
noch mal ganz anderes Thema aber Fakt
ist das eben genau bei dieser Debatte um
das bürgergerät ist genau darum geht wie
es es eigentlich ausgestaltet also das
Schonvermögen ist sehr hoch angesetzt
150.000 Euro von der vierköpfige Familie
wer hat so viel Geld auf der hohen Kante
es geht doch beim Bürgergeld und bei
Hartz IV ging es doch immer darum den
Bedürftigen zu helfen den Menschen die
auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
Beratung und Hilfe zukommen zu lassen
damit sie es wieder auf eigene Beine
schaffen die die können die die nicht
können ist eine ganz andere Frage aber
die die können und darum geht es und die
Bedürftigkeit ist einfach bei vielen
Dingen die jetzt geändert werden nicht
mehr gegeben sie meint eigentlich eine
Anspruchshaltung der Staat würde schon
richten die förderdienst
Folgen ja dass das kann passieren aber
das muss nicht sein und deswegen sagen
wir ja als Union das ist da
Nachbesserungsbedarf gibt deswegen haben
wir auch als in den Bundesländern vom
Bundesländer Seite aus Nachbesserungen
gefordert für die
bundesratsverhandlungen also das unsere
Position und ich glaube dass am Ende des
Tages geht es auch um das
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden der Menschen
gerade die die 40 Stunden die Woche
arbeiten die jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen
es ist nicht vermittelbar dass jemand
der in Vollzeit arbeitet und nur wenig
mehr rausbekommt als jemand der nicht
arbeitet das als gerecht zu definieren
lesen Sie hier mehr mit ihrer Partei
zufrieden bei der Landwirtschaft waren
es ja nicht da waren sie ja nicht so oft
Frau Kleins Nenner gehen Sie jetzt mit
ich gehe mit und finde ich finde es auch
gut dass frau Klein jetzt gesagt hat wir
haben kein Fachkräftemangel den haben
wir sowieso aber wir haben vor allem ein
Arbeitermangel es gibt ja keinen mehr
gucken Sie mal Landwirtschaft als
Beispiel sie finden doch keinen mehr
kein deutschen der spargelsticht also
grundsätzlich muss ich Arbeit natürlich
lohnen das muss glaube ich hier alle
einig aber grundsätzlich muss man
natürlich auch die Leute die ich sag's
mal bewusst sich zu Hause ist gemütlich
machen in der sozialen Hängematte davon
kenne ich persönlich auch welche die
gibt es nun mal sehen
aber ich nicht und deswegen ist ja die
Wahrheit es gibt genügend die sich da
gemütlich machen und ich war hier in
Berlin bis 2010 Polizeibeamter ich war
da selbst in den Häuser unterwegs
und die muss man einfach mal wieder an
die Arbeit kriegen weil es genau wie sie
sagen diejenigen die in einem niedlich
Lohn oder im mittleren lohnsegment
unterwegs sind die die können doch die
Hände nur im Kopf zusammenschlagen dass
die Arbeiten gehen und am Ende 150 €
vielleicht am Meer im Monat haben das
ist doch nicht gerecht ich bin ein
sozial eingestellter Mensch ich liebe
diesen Sozialstaat aber der muss auch
bezahlt werden und muss auch langfristig
bezahlt werden da kommen Kosten auf uns
zu ich weiß gar nicht wie der Staat das
alles wuppen will und da muss man Leute
in Arbeit kriegen das ist einfach so
also ich wohne in der Nähe vom Bahnhof
Zoo und wenn ich mir da die vielen
bedürftigen anschaue die von der
Bahnhofsmission Essen bekommen und
Kleidung bekommen dann sind das nicht
unbedingt Leute die fähig sind zu
arbeiten okay Leute die haben deswegen
habe ich das gesagt die die können das
ganze ist unterschreiben
aber da gibt es auch sie müssen doch
zustimmen oder meinen Sie allen Ernstes
dass er alle drin sitzen 2,4 Millionen
Arbeitslose davon sind ja die die
Maßnahmen sind und die Sozialhilfe am
Finger sind gar nicht mitgezählt dass
sie alle nicht arbeiten können
vielleicht wollen auch einige nicht
arbeiten und da muss man schon gewissen
Anreiz haben weil die anderen die
bezahlen Harald wie nehmen sie die
Stimmung in dem Land war
ich fahre mich gerade über was wir reden
reden wir konkret über das Bürgergeld
oder reden wir über die Debattenkultur
wie gehen wir miteinander um wie wie
diskutieren wir wird wenn Sie mehr ein
Halbsatz sage ich falsch sagen der mir
nicht passt sind schlechter Mensch so
empfinde ich im Moment viele
Diskussionen und das halte ich für den
Demokratie eine Katastrophe ich glaube
wir reden seit wir angefangen am vorhin
über Katha um ab über Abwägung weil wir
unsere Meinung äußern dürfen anders wo
ist das nicht so schmerzlos zu haben
das ist Demokratie an der Abwägung und
ich bin völlig bei Ihnen wenn ein Land
wie Deutschland bei all dem Problem ist
heute gibt eine solche armutquote hat
das ist ein Skandal seine Katastrophe
absolut ein menschliche Katastrophe aber
ja es gibt auch andere Dinge über die
muss man reden und das ist dann euer Job
abhängig und ja genau ich bin nicht kein
schlechter Mensch wenn ich mir ein
Fußballspiel angucke bei dieser Karte WM
aber jeder der es nicht möchte ich
möchte im Gespräch bleiben und zwar ein
Gespräch über über vielleicht hast du an
der Stelle mehr recht da das ist so habe
ich Demokratie immer verstanden und am
Ende muss es irgendeine Lösung geben die
so nah wie möglich am Optimum ist nicht
mehr und nicht weniger aber so wie das
zurzeit in vielen läuft und wir bewegen
uns dann so auf die Trump wenn wir mit
dem Finger auf trampoo die USA gezeigt
wie wie da das Land gespalten wird und
wie es nur noch gute und schlechte gibt
und zwar leider beiderseits auch Herr
Ralf das war ein wunderschönes Schluss
Plädoyer ich werde mir das nachher sogar
noch mal aufschreiben das war auf den
Punkt genau das was wir eigentlich auch
mit fingerabend erreichen wollen schönen
Abend noch wir sehen uns nächste Woche
Dienstag tschüss machen sie es gut
[Musik]